hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
review of ready player one the new movie
directed by Steven Spielberg based on
the novel by Ernest Cline about a
contest set in a global virtual reality
video game hey you may have seen some of
new rockstars other videos breaking down
the countless Easter eggs and the
trailers and since ready player one is a
story centered on hidden easter eggs as
a plot device in a cunning is a big part
of what we do here this was really an
overwhelming joyride for us those
showers could not be cold enough yeah
gross I know eventually we'll cover all
of the Easter eggs in this movie but for
right now I want to dive a bit deeper
and analyze why this film is winning
over so many of us and what details in
the movie might bug you and don't worry
if you haven't seen the movie yet
because this is a spoiler free review
okay at its core ready player one poses
a central question can a video game be a
movie or can a movie be a video game
ready player one follows Wade Watts
a kid living in the year 2045 when
society escapes the troubles of the real
world into a virtual reality network
called the Oasis that was created by an
eccentric game designer named James
Halliday who after his death left a
video will and testament teasing an
Easter Egg hidden somewhere in the Oasis
that would grant control of his company
and estate worth half a trillion dollars
so Wade going under the avatar Percival
competes in various video game
challenges to win keys that will reveal
the final resting place of this egg
first of these challenges you've
probably seen the trailers it's an
impossible race through a VR version of
New York with wrecking balls and King
Kong and a t-rex by the way this race
was a new creation for the movie first
challenge splayed out a lot differently
in the book now video games have
specific rules to them that are
different from movies and books even
when no stories are set in video game
worlds video games must balance user
interaction with narrative the
experience of you exploring the world
and searching and battling and killing
and deciphering that has to be the
source of the thrills while the
narrative beats in the cutscenes are
just bridges that get you to the next
challenge
movies meanwhile are obviously all
cutscenes zero interaction just a
director's vision for a narrative for
you to sit back and experience and react
to now of course there have been more
and more exceptions to this dividing
line a game like The Last of Us was
arguably propelled more by its cinematic
cutscenes and emotional
driven narrative meanwhile a movie like
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world used a video
game aesthetic structured with a series
of bosses to be defeated and characters
turning into coins when they're beaten
ready player one is trying to pull off
that kind of crossover but in a whole
new way it's a movie about gaming told
in a way that evokes the same visual
thrill the detail discovering joy and
the heart pounding action that a great
video game gives us and I would say for
the most part Steven Spielberg succeeded
in that challenge in three key ways
first the film is truly immersive with
dizzying escapism really this is just
such a fun film to look at the oasis in
this film is presented as a place that
you'd really want to spend all of your
time in like the best games Spielberg's
effects team put so much care into the
design of the Oasis wrestling leaves the
way VR touch translates into physical
sensation in the real world Wow
the little details of what it looks like
when avatars log out a common complaint
from some critics is that some movies
put too much emphasis on spectacle over
substance
for example James Cameron's Avatar or
the Marvel films but I think we forget
that when it comes to movies sometimes
it's okay for the spectacle to be the
substance visual effects has been a key
component to the art form of cinema
since the beginning visionaries like
Spielberg and George Lucas understood
the importance of escapism in movies and
it's why they and most other directors
prefer audiences to see movies on a big
screen in theaters and ready player one
Spielberg recognized that for a lot of
gamers immersion is everything and it's
okay for movies to embrace that too now
the second win for ready player one was
the joy it evokes and the way that it
uses pop culture to tell the story as I
mentioned before a ready player one is a
story all about Easter eggs and that
hunt is an interesting driving force
that also makes the movie itself a hunt
for us to catch all the cameos it's a
same kind of joy that you get when
you're watching movies like the lego
movies or a Pixar movie or the animated
background gags on shows like Rick and
Morty there's just so much detail packed
in the periphery and one things I liked
about the book is that it points out
that Easter eggs and hidden details
really started in the world of gaming
Clues hidden by the game designers for
only the most obsessive gamers to find
and as we're seeing now with movies and
TV that whole idea of a deeper level of
meaning and engagement that you might
have missed the first time around has
driven so
much of what we love today it's honestly
why this YouTube channel exists now the
abundant pop-culture nostalgia is
actually one of the main criticisms for
the novel and the movies reference II
promotional campaign some have called it
nostalgia porn supplanting real
storytelling and character development
with fanboy ISM and what South Park
would call member berries no no III
don't remember buckaroo banzai
like most eighties references I just
like pretend to know it but while the
books connections to pop culture feel at
times exhaustive just list some lists of
nerd properties and beat for beat
descriptions of 80s movies Cline and
Spielberg did a really effective job
trimming that down in the movie to set
decoration for humor in ways that
advance the story specifically there is
one amazing sequence right in the middle
of the movie that I will not spoil here
and I actually suggest you avoid written
reviews so that you don't get spoiled
because they're talking about it and I
don't really annoyingly the sequence
evokes nostalgia and such a surprising
and interesting form honestly one of my
favorite movie moments ever but like
great video games ready player one gives
viewers two ways to enjoy the movie
straightforward engaging storyline for
the normal viewer and a world of Secrets
to dig up for the more obsessed viewer
and that leads us to the third success
of ready player one its speed while
movies can typically alternate between
fast and slow and some movies are
deliberately slow which is totally fine
video games by their nature must be more
thrilled aced and when a movie allows
itself to be paced at breakneck speeds
the way games can be that can lead to
some very exciting results movies like
Mad Max fury road and baby driver were
essentially full movie length chase
sequences and they were two of my
favorite movies from recent years they
proved that the ride doesn't have to
stop until the credits roll ready player
one has a similar pacing quality to it
once the game begins it doesn't really
stop one action sequence really just
leads to the next anything the movies
live-action segments feel like cutscenes
to the VR gameplay and that leads me to
one major gripe I have with the movie as
successful as ready player one is at
producing excitement from watching
gamers explore in battle and hunt for
Easter eggs it's just not that much fun
to watch other people play video games
look look I get it
lots of people are into it there are a
ton of popular channels on YouTube
and twitch where people just watch great
gamers do their thing and talk about it
but for me there just isn't a whole lot
of emotional stakes and watching an
animated avatar remember something about
an old Atari game and that alone being
the key to his success and don't get me
wrong there can be stakes with avatars
playing virtual games that represent
real life conflict the movie wargames
which by the way it plays a major role
in the story of the ready player one
book stages its climax with an AI
supercomputer playing tic-tac-toe with
itself and it works because the outcome
of those games determines whether or not
the world will get destroyed in nuclear
war the stakes are existential and dead
serious also movies like The Matrix and
Inception and avatar use a similar meta
level conceit where characters getting
hurt and their avatar bodies doesn't
necessarily mean they're dead but for
the most part those movies do a really
good job to blink the avatar versions of
the characters with their real bodies
and they keep us invested in the heroes
literal safety now ready player one does
have a few powerful reminders of
real-world stakes early on but it kind
of loses itself in video game action a
little too much for me in the second
half it's kind of like watching a
skilled gamer do a speedrun the
victories just start to feel a little
easy in all great stories we want to see
a hero struggle and change give up
something that they love to achieve
something that they didn't know they
wanted but needed so I would love to see
a version of the ready player one book
in movie where Wade Watts pars of all
realizes his nerdy obsessions while
somewhat of a superpower is also a flaw
that holds them back and then it takes
more than an encyclopedic knowledge of a
celebrity and pop culture to get ahead
in life or to do what Spielberg
Illustrated so well in his movies Close
Encounters of the Third Kind that
obsession and dogged pursuit of the
truth leaves one feeling incomplete and
isolated from the world that feels
familiar
but uh nope remember ready player one is
a young adult novel and this movie is
meant for kids we don't want to think
about life when we're kids who wanted to
escape it and win it so if that
childhood desire results in an enjoyable
beautiful two-hour long video game
cutscene filled with references to my
childhood I'm all for it
and if letter grades matter to you I
don't know a B b-plus b-plus yeah we
give bonus points for that amazing
midsection sequence that's impossible to
overlook it's that great but a question
I want to throw ever to you guys if you
had access to the Oasis and could pick a
cinematic universe or video game to
spend all your time in what would it be
me easy aliens I would be the first
volunteer for a Weyland exposition -
lv-426 some Gunter's love finding eggs I
just want to shoot them with grenades
comment down below to let me know your
thoughts or tweet me directly at a vas
and follow the rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos I also want to
give a quick shout out and thanks to
Stardust and RealD 3d for screening
ready player once so early so I could
get in and watch it actually go check
out my first take reaction to the movie
right after the screening ended on new
rockstars start us page and like this
video and subscribe to new rock stars
for more in depth breakdowns of stuff
like ready player one stranger things
watch as I spend all of my time scouring
all these new properties for every last
one of these Easter eggs so you can
enjoy your time [ __ ]
by